(crowd applauding)
- [Kelly] Where, yeah,
it's like musical chairs.
- Yes.
- Scootch in.
(Kelly giggles)
- Hello!
- Nice to meet you.
- [Michael] Nice to meet you.
- Yes, have y'all ever met before?
- This is our-
- [Kelly] First time?
- Is it your turn to
talk, my turn to talk?
- No, go talk, you talk.
- You talk!
It's your turn.
- You're talking.
- Okay.
(Kelly giggles)
- It's nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, too.
(Kelly and crowd giggle)
- I love that.
I love that both of
you're like, have we met?
Like, this happens often on the couch.
'Cause we run into people
and you can't remember all the time
'cause it's out of context.
- [Julianne] Yeah.
- [Michael] Yeah.
- But anyway, congrats.
This is your second
Vegas residency, right?
- That's correct.
- That's incredible.
- I know.
- You did so well, you got another one.
(Julianne cheers)
(crowd applauds)
- Yeah.
- I'm so-
- So what's your show called?
- What's it called?
- [Kelly] What's it called?
- Michael Carbonaro: Live in Las Vegas.
We went crazy with the title.
- I would've never guessed that.
- That's a good one, right?
- Yeah, original.
- It's so funny with magicians,
Vegas is really like the
golden ring to catch.
- Yeah.
- You know, like, I had a TV show.
I had five seasons, 120 episodes.
- Yeah.
- Original magic.
But it wasn't until I
was performing in Vegas
that all my friends and family like,
you'd finally made it.
- Yeah.
(crowd laughs)
- Like now I made it?
Oh, right.
- Cool.
(Kelly chuckles)
It is!
- Oh, you're gonna be there too.
- It is, I am, I'm gonna be there as well.
Yeah.
- We should do
a little number.
- I know!
First of all, I love magic,
so I am probably going
to come to your show.
I love it.
I'm a child when it comes to magic.
(Julianne laughs)
Like I love for my mind to people.
- That's what it does
for you really, right?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Brings back that wonder.
- And it's like a,
I don't feel like I got to
see a lot of magic as a child.
So like making up-
- [Michael] You were deprived.
- For it, I was deprived.
Very bereft childhood.
So what can people expect from your show?
- Well-
- Other than magic?
- That's-
(all laughing)
That was what I was gonna say.
- [Kelly] Dammit!
(Julianne and crowd laugh)
- Yeah, there will be wonder.
There's magic.
(Kelly and crowd laugh)
I'll make people, I'll make them laugh.
And you might even leave
believing that magic is real.
- I do.
- I do, too!
- You believe in magic, too?
- Yes, I do!
- [Kelly] I do.
- Do you believe it?
I'm kind of a hard maybe on that.
(Julianne laughs)
- That's incredibly sad
since you're a magician.
- Well, I mean, maybe it's
because I'm a magician.
- Okay, 'cause you know, yeah.
So you do some pranking.
- That's right.
- Which I, don't prank me.
So can you share a tip-
- Watch out!
(Kelly laughs)
(Julianne and crowd laugh)
- Like, I hate to be pranked.
- Okay.
- Can you share a tip with us though?
Like, if I wanted to prank someone?
- I think the number one thing I learned
doing all the pranking TV shows
was that you gotta, you know
like the eighties movies,
The Goonies, like "Goonies never die."
- "Goonies never say die."
(crowd applauds)
That's the line.
(Kelly laughs)
- You're right.
It's "Goonies never say die."
You just keep going
even when you think
someone's not believing it.
- Yeah.
- Because a lot of times
people will say like,
that's not real.
And you're like, you're right.
Like, you wanna like let it go
but like they're just
kind of poking at it.
So you have to just keep
going no matter what.
Goonies never-
- Pretend you're a narcissist,
and just keep going with the lie.
(Julianne laughs)
- Yeah, hold onto it until the very end.
So how do you come up with your tricks?
How do you do that?
- I listen to the secret
invisible fairies-
(Kelly laughs)
that float around my head.
- Here in my head, all of them.
- You know, anything
can be, a lot of coffee.
Oh, this is, thank you.
- Is that coffee?
Yes.
- No, that's so funny though,
I said I needed coffee.
I meant in the dressing room.
- Oh, there you go, we got you sugar.
- Thank you.
Oh, I was like, I wanna talk.
- You're welcome.
- I didn't need it for out here-
- We aim to please on
the Kelly Clarkson show.
- But now that I have it.
- Sip, yeah.
- Coffee does help.
- I have tea.
There you go.
- You guys were wine,
is that wine in there?
- No, I have, I had wine.
Oh, damn, they took it.
They're so quick.
(Julianne and crowd laugh)
It's like, they're like,
she's got a problem.
Take the wine away.
- I used to drink, do you drink coffee?
- I do.
- Do you drink it black?
- I drink it in many ways.
- [Michael] Oh.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
- Depending on what mood I'm in.
- [Kelly] Yes!
- I drink with reconstituted sugar.
- [Julianne] Oh.
- What the hell does that mean?
(crowd laughs)
- Well, this is just regular sugar,
but I-
- What's reconstituted?
What does that mean?
I don't know what that means.
- Oh, you don't know reconstituted sugar?
It takes out-
- Do you know what that means?
I don't know what that means.
- It takes out the
calories from the sugar.
- You know, that's why I
don't know what this means.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm gonna teach you how
to reconstitute sugar.
- I don't reconstitute much.
- I do hand-
- My friend.
(everyone laughs)
- I hand-reconstitute the sugar.
- [Kelly] Okay, wait, what?
- So you pour the sugar.
- [Julianne] Oh.
- Okay.
- Into your hand.
- [Julianne] Yeah.
- You could buy it
reconstituted already.
- Okay.
- But having it,
if you just do it in your hand like that
and it's a reconstitute
and then you kind of just hold
it up in the air like that.
So you can see.
You can see it.
Look, look, look, look.
There's like little
pieces of it right there
floating right there.
- No, it, there's not.
- Yep, you see it?
- It's gone.
(crowd giggles)
- Catch it and then when it
reconstitutes it comes back,
and it doesn't have to-
- What the hell!
(Julianne screaming)
- doesn't have the calories anymore.
(crowd applauding)
Yeah so.
(Julianne laughing)
- Did you see it?
Did you see it happen?
- No!
He had nothing in his hands.
- Oh my gosh.
I didn't even know-
- Still tastes as good.
- you were going into a magic trick.
I almost ruined your thing with my-
- That's the prank!
(Julianne laughs)
- I know, I'm so sorry.
I like totally pulled out
the Webster dictionary
and was like, what does that mean?
That is incredible.
- Thank you.
- Oh my god.
You're so cool.
- You try it!
You could try it.
- Totally.
I can make it disappear
just 'cause I eat it.
(everyone laughs)
So wait, you've got something else to show
Julianne and myself, right?
You got something to show us, right?
- You want more?
- [Julianne and Kelly] I want more!
- Okay, let's do an experiment over there.
- Okay, let's do it,
let's do it, let's do it.
- Alright, come on over here.
- Okay.
- Yes, we had them get us some-
- God I love magic.
Is that it? Yes.
- Okay.
- Some sodas.
- You guys can stand over here.
- Not just soda.
This is Texas, y'all.
Dr. Pepper.
- That's right.
Here, you want to pick one each?
- Sure okay, cool.
Well, I'm not going diet.
- I'm a diet.
- Of course.
(crowd laughs)
- So in this experiment,
in every experiment there is a control,
and there is a subject.
Yours, Julianne and will be the control.
We're gonna keep this one right here.
Not gonna touch it.
Gonna keep it perfectly still.
- Great.
- You could watch over that,
okay?
- [Kelly and Julianne] Okay.
- Yours-
- Locked in.
- Is gonna be the subject.
- Okay.
- This can, we're gonna take it,
we're gonna shake it
up as much as possible
building up all that carbonation,
and then I'm gonna open it in your face.
- Great.
(Julianne and crowd laugh)
- Okay?
- Great.
- It is?
- I'm actually okay with it.
(Kelly laughs)
- She's a-
- My makeup artist
isn't, but I am.
- You are a believer in magic.
- Yes, I am.
- Do you guys really do
believe in magic?
- Yes.
- Okay, so I'm gonna give it a shake.
- Okay.
- You can hear it shaking.
- I hear it.
I'm shaking too.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but I know a lot of people think,
oh well Michael Carbonaro,
you're a master manipulator.
You're not even really shaking that can.
You're just moving time
and space around you.
(crowd laughs)
Get that a lot.
- You're like a superhero.
- So you're gonna do it.
- Okay, I'm gonna do it.
- Come on over here.
- Okay.
- And maybe if they get, would
you give us a little music?
Some can-shaking music.
Oh, you shake it up.
(easy upbeat music)
- [Kelly] I shake it? Okay.
- [Michael] Yeah, there you go.
Yeah right.
The other hand too!
(Kelly giggles)
Double-handed, both on the can.
- Okay, okay, okay.
- [Michael] Do a spin!
- Oh, double spin.
- Yeah, there we go.
- Full spin, full spin.
- Okay, we're good, we're good.
We'll leave it right there.
- Looked bad for a minute there, Michael.
- Here comes the magic.
Kelly, take the straw.
- Okay.
- Aim the straw right at the can.
- Make a big circle in the air.
Big circle in the air,
big circle in the air.
Good, that grabs up all the carbonation.
- What?
- You take it, we aim it over here.
- Okay.
- Big circle, big circle, big circle.
- Big circle, big circle.
(drum trills)
- And it's done!
- What?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- Come here.
(crowd laughs)
- What happened?
- There's no (censored) way.
(crowd laughs)
(drum rolls)
- You said you believed in magic.
- No, I, but I-
(pop tab clicks)
(Kelly screams)
(crowd laughs)
(Julianne screams)
- What?
(crowd cheers)
How did you do that?
- You did it, Kelly, you did it.
(Julianne laughs)
- How did it not? I don't understand.
- [Julianne] Oh my gosh.
- You transferred it invisibly through.
- With your energy.
- It's chemicals, don't test!
- It's real.
(Julianne laughs)
It's real.
- Good.
- That was incredible, wait, what?
- Oh.
- We haven't touched it.
- I know.
Is it gonna explode?
- See, now you believe in magic.
- No, yeah.
(Julianne giggles)
- Possibly.
(pop tab clicks)
(Julianne screams)
(crowd cheers)
- I don't understand!
- What!
(Kelly laughs)
(crowd cheers)
- I don't understand.
Alright, you have to see him live.
Check out Michael Carbonaro Live in Vegas
at the Rio and the Pen and Teller theater.
May 25th to July 2nd.
Head over to KellyClarksonShow.com
to learn more.
We will be right back, that was crazy.